- So Mike, you get your first signing bonus,
what'd you do with it?
- [Vick] So in my mind, you know, I'm like,
we're gonna get $3 million.
So, you know, I talked to all my aunts, my mom,
my sisters. Got everybody in a huddle
and was, like, "Look, this the play.
Aunt Tina, I'mma give you $50,000 and, you know,
a nice GMC truck.
Aunt Joyce, I'mma give you $100,000 and—."
Mom was a given, you know, she was the jewel
so she was gonna get whatever she wanted.
Get the check.
So I open it up, and I look at it, and I just
look at my mom, and she lookin' like
she thought it was a blank check
or she thought it was a joke
or we had been punked or something.
The check said $1.9 million.
I'm like, "Uh-oh. Mom, we got a problem,
Houston, we got a problem, for sure."
- They took that much out?
That GMC all of a sudden turned into a what?
- The GMC turned into, like, a Camaro.
- [Laughing]
- That was tougher than goin' to prison.
Straight up. It's a lot of money.
I wanted to kick myself in the ass, for real.
- [Master laughing]